okay so obi-wan kenobi episode 4 is now
out and the brand new entry is packed
with easter eggs hidden details and
callbacks to the greatest star wars law
the show has had its ups and downs over
the last couple of weeks but this feels
like we're getting to the good stuff now
with more of the plot points falling
into place throughout this video we're
going to be breaking it all down and if
this is your first time here this is the
heavy spoiler show i'm your host paul
aka the highlander who knows that can be
obi-wan
so bad now let's get into the breakdown
okay so last week we watched as obi-wan
and leia travel to mapuzo an empire
stronghold that was first featured in a
star wars role-playing game here they
ran into tala a member of the
underground railroad-esque smuggling
group that took jedi off world to
sanctuary known as the path this was
brought up in rebels and we discovered
that quinlan vos had been part of the
organization huge shout outs to you guys
for also pointing out on the last video
that amongst the names on the wall were
also din atlas reganda is marin and also
valen halcyon now it wasn't too long
before vader showed up and i also forgot
to point out that him roasting obi-wan
is something that he's dreamed about
ever since he took the moral high ground
on him the comics actually featured a
sequence where vader fantasized about
their battle on mustafar and in it he
suspended obi-wan in the air before
dragging him through the lava like what
we had played out in the show he clearly
wanted to prolong his suffering and he's
been roasted obi-wan's been roasted too
and don't worry owen you'll get your
chance as well
[Applause]
also they added lola into the intro now
which is a nice detail now we open with
old ben on a bed healing up after his
battle with vader this somewhat riffs on
luke's escape at the end of empire in
which he recovered guys taken to a
bacter tank and we're in for some
flashbacks
now what this is in place for is to show
the similarities between both vader and
obi-wan who are now both recovering
after the fight due to the isolation
that one feels inside a tank like this
it actually heightens one's ability to
meditate and this is how the pair reach
out to one another isolation chambers
like this are used in a lot of spores i
know because i've been to one like this
and it's also why it was picked as
something that 11 floated in during the
last season of stranger things could the
fortress inquisitorius and leia is
giving it the biggen about being the
daughter of a senator and the princess
of alderaan won't be for much longer
love
and also this is put in place to mirror
the opening of a new hope when she
talked about the diplomatic mission that
they were apparently on now one thing we
forgot to mention last week is how
leia's outfits have all mirrored moments
from the original trilogy there was a
burgundy and white one which appeared in
episode 1 and this was riffing on what
she wore on bespin and empire the
burgundy was then taken away so that it
was just white which is what she wore in
a new hope obi-wan then ended up putting
a green cover over this and as we
mentioned in our first video this rift
on what she wore on endor in return of
the jedi and we also think that leia
will meet vader at some point in the
series during a new hope when they come
across each other she does talk like
they've met before so i get the feeling
that they will interact at some point
during this whether vader will realize
she's force sensitive or not remains to
be seen and perhaps his feelings will
cloud his judgment with her like they
did with luke this was during a time
that palpatine ordered his legions to
hunt down force sensitive kids
throughout the galaxy and the
inquisitors especially were responsible
for hundreds of deaths the ones that
they believed they could turn were
drafted into their ranks and it's gonna
be interesting to see how this goes i
love this dark mirror the sith are
currently doing where they're very much
reflecting the jedi obi-wan last episode
talked about how he had a brother called
ob2 but he was taken away from his
family by the order this obviously had
its positives with characters like
anakin who were freed from slavery but a
lot were also taken away from very
prosperous lives the sith also took
children too but whereas the jedi taught
them love and compassion the inquisitors
were taught hate and also fear as we
know there are only normally over two
main sith lords a master and an
apprentice and this is why they're
constantly backstabbed while front
stabbing each other in order to gain
power riva very much represents the life
of a child taken in by a sith and her
backstory will no doubt flash this out
more now though the main plot of the
entry revolves around saving leia so she
doesn't die it is likely that she might
have had an even worse fate the
inquisitors would have likely discovered
she's force sensitive and tormented her
until she became one of them once her
dear old dad found out that she was
alive he would have of course carried
out the mission that he wanted to do
with luke at his side which was to
overthrow the emperor it's wild to think
we could have got a what if alternate
universe where she and her dad ended up
ruling the galaxy but that's something
for the fan fiction kids now this entire
scene is of course a metaphor for the
nazis and people that harbour jews
during the second world war jewish
sympathizers were often interrogated
beaten and murdered for helping the
jewish citizens escape or hide and
there's a lot of danger involved in
harboring them this is further hammered
home in the next scene when we cut to
icecube's son o'shea jackson jr he wants
obi-wan taking off world instantly and
we quickly discover this is the
foundations of the path leia is an asset
and she knows everything and as we know
from rogue one her father bail would be
extremely important we learned that
roelkin now lives his life in fear
because his wife was force sensitive
jedi aren't allowed to love and her
getting married shows she wasn't even
part of the order still they hunted her
down and ended up killing her broken
agrees to help them go to nur and in a
cool technology call back we get a
hologram that looks like it's riffing on
the one from return of the jedi this
carries the same style as what was used
when the rebels planned out the end or
death star missions and its year we
learn the fortress is unknown this two
featured is a level at the end of fall
in order and the planet is a water moon
that juxtaposes the lava landscape that
exists on mustafar obi-wan ends up
breaking into it much in the same way
that kyle kesters did in the game there
are theories that he'll pop up in the
show and the second game is rumored to
feature around this time but i'm not
sure if we'll have the groundwork but
for this to all tie into that tala still
has imperial clearance and with obi-wan
they fly to nur but there's no way
obi-wan feels ready now he still
possesses some of his abilities but not
enough to match vader and i think he's
gonna need a big pep talk before he gets
into it with him now qui-gon is someone
who's been hinted at throughout the
entire show it's taken
liam neeson long enough to come back to
the star wars universe and i'm sure it
won't be too long until we see him again
now you'll know that be aware that
there's not force ghosts popping up
every 15 seconds and this is because
once it did i died they typically stayed
dead their bodies didn't disintegrate
into nothing like what we saw in the
original trilogy and though qui-gons
didn't do this either after he was
mauled he did find a way to come back
this is because qui-gon had a certain
set of skills skills that make him a
nightmare for people like palpatine
quicker was actually in touch with a
living force and thus when he died he
became absorbed by it this is how yoda
was able to communicate with him through
meditation in revenge of the sith and he
also said that he'd pass this ability
onto obi-wan though he's not having much
luck with it he of course shut himself
off from the force and he's very much
dealing with mixed emotions because of
anakin and the guilty feels over him
therefore he's not really at peace which
is why he's not hearing back from his
former master qui-gon's voice also
popped up at the end of rise of
skywalker when the jedi were calling to
rey so his voice has been part of things
in the franchise rise red
we stand behind you ray
whether they end up fully bringing him
back in costume remains to be seen but i
hope that we do get liam neeson back i
actually think that ob1 will probably be
at its lowest point next week and then
qui-gon will appear and give him a big
pep talk so that he's hyped up to head
into the final battle for episode six
let me know below if you disagree though
and also yeah like the video yeah
subscribe will it will you mate it'd be
much appreciated if you do that thank
you now at this point we cut back to
riva who brings a bell nab this planet
first appeared in clone wars episode 6
and it was a home to castaways this
makes it the perfect place for the path
which is what reeve is after though she
tells leia she can go home if she
snitches i think this is a lie and not
really something that the imperials
would do as we saw what they did to
alderaan when they asked her questions
in a new hope tala lands at the fortress
and we see a ship here that looks very
similar to the one featured at the start
of force awakens they also do the
clearance scene you know the one they do
in loads of movies mission impossible
and all that but she bluffs her way
through by pulling rank she ends up
earning a path for obi-wan who swims
into the base with a re-breather on this
whole scene is of course riffing on the
one from the phantom menace in which he
and qui-gon swam into gungan city riva
reaches into leia's mind which is a
technique that kylo ren did in the force
awakens similar to rey it doesn't work
on leia and thus riva has to open up
about her past in order to try and find
some common ground with her she also
brings up the fact that they both have
droids i think that we will no doubt
soon discover that she was the child at
the jedi temple in the opening scene i'm
surprised they've not already confirmed
it and i'm guessing that this hasn't
been put in place yet so it reflects
later riva hates obi-wan and it's likely
because she discovered that he returned
to coruscant but that he didn't go
looking for the younglings she probably
feels like she was abandoned and seeing
him go out of his way to rescue another
young child might annoy her even more
because she was left behind however i
think that if she sees he's been
protecting both her and luke that she'll
realize he's not the evil man she's
built up in her head and that if he had
known she was there that he would have
tried to save her now this moment is
important as we discover at the end of
the episode that it's during this that
she placed the tracking device inside
lola we don't actually see this moment
per se but she does have the flaps open
as she toys with it tala is captured and
she leaves her [ __ ] device behind which
we see resting on a table a similar shot
of this popped up in a new hope when
c-3po and r2d2 ended up having to hide
after the imperials searched for them on
the death star speaking of searching we
also see the ominous seeker droids which
are of course based upon probes they
even emit the same sound and their red
eye is really intimidating rb1 ends up
sneaking around past stormtroopers which
is also what he did on the death star
they chat away just like how they did at
the tractor beam and he ends up
distracting them with a sound much like
how he did in a new hope again it's sort
of like poetry they rhyme and tyler
busts up some heads to get back to his
station now as for the grand inquisitor
we actually had somewhat of an update on
him again last week joby harold head
writer for the series ended up speaking
to variety and inevitably it got round
to the character harold didn't say
whether he was alive or not but he did
say they'd never break cannon and as we
know he does pop up in rebels long after
this series takes place he eventually
died after the battle with kane and
jairus in the series and due to failing
vader his spirit was forced to be a
ghost that guarded a holocron for the
villain i've already been over this in
my episode 1 and 2 breakdown so i don't
want to just repeat myself but with a
cannon comment i'm guessing that
everything will stay exactly how we know
it to be malaya holds up under
interrogation and they end up taking her
to a torture machine similar to the one
that showed up in empire this also
popped up in rebels and it was used to
get information out of people for the
imperials in the secure sector obi-wan
discovers what the place really is and
we see jedi trapped inside amber-like
substances
this place isn't a fortress
it's a tomb
huge shout outs to simon a bearman on
twitter for pointing out that obi-wan
says it's not a fortress it's a tomb
which could also be a nod to the
fellowship of the rings
this is no mine
it's a tomb now these look like they're
all ones that the inquisitors have
captured but it begs the question why
they didn't bring nary in i understand
that he was used as an example but it is
strange that they didn't select him with
this being a secure area i actually have
a theory that it might have been
developed as a way to try and clone jedi
we know from the mandalorian and rise of
skywalker that this was a girl carried
out by the imperials and it would make
sense to have jedi stored here i think
that one of the ones we come across is
tara sanub an investigator that used the
force to help solve crimes i'm sure the
others are famous ones too so if you
know them then let me know in the
comments below and there are
conversations on twitter that this is
mace windu but i've zoomed in on it and
i don't think that it's him in all
honesty these could be carbonite
chambers though that hold people in
stasis and who knows they could bring
him back through that anyway that's the
end of every time every time every time
speaking of time toler buys them some
and requests an audience with reaver in
the room we see several lightsabers on
display and these are the ones that the
inquisitors collected from the jedi they
took down toler tells riva that the path
is on forum a desert planet that too
popped up in the clone wars obi-wan
rescues lair and i love this scene in
the dark man's got an old lead yeah
don't mean to brag and watching how
black the room was whilst the lightsaber
popped up was such a cool moment they
alert the seekers and this too allows
taller a chance to get out as well and
as we learned last week she is a quick
draw obi-wan cuts through the
stormtroopers in the hallway giving me
battle droid vibes and we also see reba
with a perch trooper these are
specialized soldiers and they were
drafted into the inquisitor ranks to
help hunt down the jedi it gets stuck in
a corridor and the water starts to flood
through the cracks this is exactly the
same places where cal ford vader and
obi-wan even ends up using the force to
stop water from coming in much like how
vader did in the game obi wan don's a
trench coat and hey i can see he's got
four legs arrest that man now it's not
too long before they get found out but
in typical star wars fashion someone
comes in to save the day speeders burst
in and buy them an escape route and even
the poor little mouse droid he's not
safe now these speeders seem like
earlier models and we can catch their
cockpit doors opening differently to how
they do an empire we hear that one of
the forces is called wayne and though
this could be an underweight vox from
star wars demolitions the character dies
before the game takes place vader is
angry as hell and at this point he's
completely off the leash he dangles riva
in the air before almost killing her
however she gets herself a stay of
execution after revealing that they
placed a tracker on the ship this was
something that was also used to track
the rebels to yavin foreign a new hope
another being saying saw like poetry
they rhyme now it's a bittersweet rescue
as they lost the team member in order to
get lair out war has a heavy toll and i
really enjoyed the way that they shot
this scene dens with leia touching
obi-wan's hand thanking him for the
rescue now i had fun with the episode
and there were a lot of things in it
that you know i just just had a blast
with it was nice seeing it does feel
like it's getting better every week and
the last two episodes have been great
entries for me however i do have my
issues and i think this show is a bit
too simplistic in all honesty i think
everything feels a bit video game side
questing me at points which is fine but
i just don't get the feeling that
there's major stakes involved because we
know how it's gonna play out there's
also not really that many characters to
push the plot in massively interesting
ways i'm actually re-watching westworld
at the moment to remind myself of all
the stuff that happened in that before
season 4 and comparing the way that that
has many subplots that all kind of tie
into this overarching narrative to this
makes me realize that it's missing major
driving forces i know they're not really
in the same ballpark plot-wise yet but
just in general tv shows tend to follow
that kind of structure so it all builds
towards the season climax whereas this
seems a bit basic i don't hate it but
i'd just like it to have a bit more me
to it now we also know that everything
is constrained to fit a new hope so
things kind of have to end about a
certain point come the end of the season
we know that luke will be fine leia will
go home too and that obi-wan invader
can't kill each other as it would throw
everything off i think once you kind of
accept the show is constrained to this
it sets your expectations but we also
know it can't really excel beyond them
and there are good aspects to it and i
think all the legacy characters like
obi-wan leia and vader are handled
really well this is the most violent
version of vader i think we've had and
disney are doing a good job with their
biggest star wars character also there's
a lot of complaints that the show is
getting review bombed because of its
rotten tomatoes audience score but i
don't know i do genuinely feel that
people are torn on it because all star
wars splits people down the middle these
days i think review bombing in general
is pointless because then it just draws
attention to things being review bombed
se there are a lot of predictable
aspects even if those aspects are a lot
of fun anyway yeah fine entry and that's
the video and obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below i
know this show is a bit divisive so yeah
that's star wars baby and i'd love to
hear what you think we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the batman on the 15th
of june and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random and the
winners of the last one are on the
screen right now so if that's you then
message me on twitter heavyspoilers if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
why we like disney's version of vader
which will be linked on screen right now
all criticisms aside i think they've
done a really good job with them and we
kind of talk about our love for the
character and why you know why why we
just like the disney version go ahead
over there right after this and thanks
for checking out this video take care
peace